[Music]
from the blockbuster franchise that
nobody loves but everybody likes enough
that they won't change the channel when
it's on cable comes to see that kinda
sounds like a high-speed [ __ ] Fast
Five wait they've make five of these
already prepare for the biggest hit of
this street racing franchise because it
got rid of all the street racing now
it's a heist film on wheels orchestrated
by Vin Diesel a passable action hero who
this time must match wits with a far
more charismatic action hero don't rock
whose jacked up on baby oil I'll see you
soon Toretto together they'll crank up
the nos on all the things you come to
expect from a fast and furious movie by
gear shifting
[Music]
mumble growls look I'm not water please
incorrect Colleen I remember everything
and obert homoeroticism to pull off one
last job Tom will need to gather
everyone's favorite heist movie
stereotypes the hunky mastermind the
nerd the Bernie Mac the guy who can't
speak English and the guy who's
constantly snacking he Rob to steal 100
million dollars with the dumbest
criminals ever as they take off their
masks during robberies increasing are
you crazy
go for leisurely strolls while all of
Rio's drug gangs are after them and drag
race cop cars they just stole down the
middle of the street these heroes will
stop at nothing to take down a sort of
ruthless drug lord by destroying poor
neighborhoods destroying rich
neighborhoods killing 22 cops with a
giant metal save
and ultimately leaving Rio and way worse
shape than when they found it it's a
hell of a mess
that is so refuel and right along while
these rebels break every law in the book
of physics gravity way differential
[Music]
and friction
buckle up for the fifth film in the
franchise that's technically the board
since the offensive past three take
place after fast six making the third
fast the six fast possibly the seventh
depending on where fast seven ends up in
the timeline Hey look car boobs story
mr. Potato Head bad Keanu the tooth
fairy
loofa Tyrese Witherspoon bouquet and
these three interchangeable tough girls
fast five wait if that quarter-mile
Street race took 60 seconds to finish
wouldn't that mean they're only driving
15 miles an hour oh we get it you can
nitpick movies but can you do this
boobs yeah fair enough thanks to the
people at cinemasins
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers all your base are belong to us
who farted banana hammock lasso lassies
legendary legless Lego Legolas viewer
discretion advised my cat's breath
smells like cat food